the cave symbolizes this limited world  that keeps us trapped and the shadows  are the only things we perceive as real  because of the limitations imposed upon  us when the prisoner escapes and gains  access to the outer world he encounters  the sun which is the absolute truth  plato makes three important points in  the allegory with regards to the truth  one that he takes time to get accustomed  to the truth and eventually re-engineer  one's perception in order to understand  it and accept it number two that once  one sees the truth and accepts it one  can never go back to their former state  and number three that the truth can be  perceived as something dangerous by some  people because often the truth hurts so  much that people will feel that it's not  worth risking what they have for  something so precarious